sky news won a bafta for our coverage of
the situation
inside ible in syria uh and our special
correspondent alex crawford who worked
on the story
i'm glad to say is with us now
hello to you alex good to see you we've
known each other for 30 odd years and
you just keep racking them up don't you
was it really 30 oh come on kate you
can't be that long
no i mean obviously this is not a a
single
person's effort this is a huge team and
i get to work with some of the best
in the business and particularly on this
program
very very lucky but also we have editors
to thank you
continue to back us and to put
very marginal largely unpopular items
and make them
issues that people sit up and care about
and think about
and a huge team in london this is a a
great
show of teamwork and i'm very proud to
be part of that team
lucky i'm the front person but very very
proud of all the
really creative talented people behind
me and to be honest
this was an opportunity which sky news
grasped
and thrust a largely forgotten
war right back there up on on the
headlines this has been going on for
10 years now more than 10 years you know
and
our editors and the people the
journalists in sky who are some of the
most passionate and dedicated
have covered this for more than a decade
now
and it's still going on now war crimes
on both sides
a sham election just a few weeks ago
which
really apparently re-elected bashar
al-assad with 95
of the vote these are astonishing
figures it prompted the whole of the
syria
conflict has prompted a mass migration
of people you remember we covered that
in 2015 it's led to enormous problems
worldwide pretty much which we're still
living with so
feel enormously proud that um sky
decided to
invest so much effort personnel and
creative talent in this
and um i hope that the politicians sit
up and take note and
see that this is still going on and
there is still no
credible political solution to this
absolutely dreadful conflict you know
they uh took charge of or tried to
involve themselves in syria to prevent
the the spread of
isis isis killed 5 000 people in syria
the bashar al-assad regime has killed
200
000 people over 10 years and that we
should take note of